give me your thoughts on Tick Tock I
know that you dug into some of the
research around that the way that it's
been weaponized and also the impact that
it's having on young people
so let me just start off by saying I
love Tick Tock
um I think it's an extraordinary product
I think it was genius to take a platform
and say it shouldn't be social it's not
about what your friends think about you
it's not about choices it's not about
finding anything you want like YouTube
it's not about
you know feeling bad about yourself
because you don't have a six-pack or
you're not as rich as your friends on
Instagram
it's about a streaming media platform
where there's no choice you have one
choice you you tap the logo and it
immediately starts calibrating based on
what you like what you swipe up swipe
down on and before you know it you're in
the ultimate tailored individualized
singular
streaming media Network that is just
addictive it's just I could I could go
on to tick tock right now and for a
couple hours just watch it I think my 12
year old boy if he had his way would
disappear into his room with his phone
put diapers on so we could watch Tick
Tock for 72 hours straight and not have
a bathroom break I think this thing is
an amazing product
uh the issue is if I were a member of
the CCP and I saw that we had vested
interest in diminishing America's
standing strategically in the world
and that the easiest way to do that was
not with Kinetic power because we don't
have the capital that the US has to
spend on aircraft carrier fleets or even
through corporate Espionage and they do
a great job of that
I would just take my thumb and very
elegantly and insidiously put it on the
scales of content
that reflects American a bad light so
whether you're Kim Kardashian or Joe
Rogan or Jonathan hi a lot of your
content reflects American a very
positive light in a lot of your content
highlights the problems we have
it would be very easy I believe they're
doing this now I think they'd be stupid
not to do this and put their thumb on
the scale of content
that says our elections are being
weaponized
racism in U.S has not gotten better it's
gotten worse
that capitalism does not work you can't
trust your leaders and slowly but surely
raise a generation of Americans of Civic
leaders military leaders Business
Leaders that feel bad about America
and also aren't focused on the human's
rights violations in China but basically
you know if you think of geopolitics as
a horror movie
it's not it's not outside threats right
now we are stronger than we've ever been
I would argue competitively no one's
lining up for Chinese or Russian
vaccines our GDP growth hasn't matched
China's but it's more consistent the
smartest brightest hardest working
people in the world all have one thing
in common and that is they like the idea
of either getting to Europe or getting
to the United States especially so we're
the football team that gets the top
draft choices every year from every High
School in the world so we're doing
really well but the horror movie would
be that horror movie where they say the
call is coming from inside the house
we're eating each other in the U.S
internally a third of Republicans and
Democrats see the other party members of
the other party is their mortal enemy 25
percent of America is comfortable with
an autocrat as long as the autocrat
represents his or her ideals 54 percent
of Democrats are worried that their kid
is going to marry a Republican
and so the fastest way to atomize or the
fastest way to defeat an enemy is
atomize them and I think Tick Tock uh
when you have kids under the age of 18
spending more time on Tick Tock than
they spent on every streaming media
company combined would we be comfortable
with Netflix Hulu Disney Plus
um HBO Max all being owned by China and
I don't think we would so I think there
needs to be a separation between
ownership and the product I think that
meta was the ultimate Espionage product
I don't think the most out in the NSA
the gru MI6 and their Wildest Dreams
could have come up
with meta and I think we're going to
find out that our ability to take out
some of these Taliban leaders has been a
function of their niece being on
Instagram we GPS drone them
uh and I also and I realize this sounds
paranoid it doesn't mean I'm wrong I
think after the Senators and the elected
leaders in America have their photo ops
berating Mark Zuckerberg they go into a
confidential hearing and he says do you
want us to continue help killing Taliban
leaders and they say yes and he says
well back the [ __ ] off I think that's
why we haven't had any meaningful
legislation against the big American
platforms but anyways
the ultimate propaganda tool is Tick
Tock I just don't I think they would be
stupid not to do this and I think we're
naive to think that they won't be able
to do it easily and I think we should I
think it presents a real National
Security risk the wild thing is that
Tick Tock content that is disintegrating
America or reducing patriotic feelings
towards it is generated by U.S in
America yeah this isn't this isn't the
Chinese creating content but because of
the dynamic of audience capture and the
reinforcement mechanism of getting that
status response
you can press your hand on the scale
that rewards creators that create a
particular type of narrative and that it
turns every individual Tick Tock user
that cares to talk about politics to be
more likely uh an unwitting unwilling
CCP agent
it's so brilliant and Insidious at the
same time and by the way let's wrap all
of this in really joyous dance videos
which makes it all feel really benign
with Justin Bieber the catastrophe and
the apocalypse will be done to a Justin
Bieber sound that's right it doesn't
really matter it all feel good and you
don't even have to put your thumb on the
scale of certain individuals and not
others it can be the content from the
same individual in this podcast
I will talk about very hopeful things
for America you know I don't think
there's anything wrong we can't fix we
50 of the world's philanthropy
originates from U.S institutions
yeah we if you were to have one Global
headline news headline for the last
hundred years would be that British
Russians and the Americans turn back
fascism the one headline for the last 50
years would be unprecedented Global
Prosperity led by America
I'll also talk about failing young men
in the U.S and how they're struggling
and they've never done young men have
never followed that cohort has fallen
further faster in the U.S and then in
history if you're Tick Tock and you have
a series of 30 seconds 30 second clips
and you're with a CCP
which narrative do you want to see
rolling more often
and it's just super super easy they
could just take they don't need any they
don't need to produce their own content
they just need to tweak the algorithm to
say in the same 60 Minutes an individual
will have Pro and anti-American content
and we're just going to slowly but
surely dial up the anti-American content
and it's from it's from someone you
trust it's from someone who also has
pro-american content so you think their
content is credible let's create a lot
of doubt about the efficacy of the
vaccines when there's there's thoughtful
discourse on both sides I would argue 90
plus percent of the thoughtful discourse
about vaccine says on a risk-adjusted
basis you should get a vaccine
and then 10 or less is doctors saying it
Alters your DNA
if I'm the CCP and I want to create
controversy and I want to get us hating
each other more
let's make that content 50 50. let's
have everyone go at each other
over the vaccines so I always say just
quite frankly if I were them that's what
I would do why spend money on aircraft
carriers why why compete on 11 playing
field when that when we have this Trojan
Horse
the size of Montana
residing in the U.S and we have this
vehicle that the upcoming generation of
Americans love and just a few small
tweaks and slowly but surely they won't
even know the movie The Sting I don't
know if you saw it uh with Robert
Redford and Paul Newman but the key to a
great con is the mark never knows they
were conned
we're all victims of propaganda right
now we all see on the left and on the
right that sways our view but we don't
think we've been fooled
it's much easier to fool someone than
convince them they've been fooled
because to acknowledge you've been
fooled it's like saying I acknowledge
I'm an ass I'm acknowledged someone's
gotten the better of me and people don't
like that
so I think it's happening now and I
don't think we know what's even
happening to us
we also don't know what's happening in
China I don't know how much truth is
behind this but I've heard that the
Chinese algorithm on Tick Tock shows a
very different sort of world it's young
and Chinese people doing engineering and
being smart and conscientious and
admirable and patriotic
another consideration is
9.6 trillion minutes of Netflix watched
in 2021
22.6 trillion minutes of tick tock
watched in 2021
given the fact that a tick tock video at
most can be 60 Seconds
and probably the average Netflix thing
is 30 minutes
that blows my mind
it's just it's it's staggering and to
your point uh the the tick tock version
the Chinese version of tick tock and
it's duyan
uh it's all aspirational look at this
kid from Shenzhen who's a concert
pianist look at the incredible research
we're doing look at these kids what
they're building in their in their high
school it's all uplifting no politics I
mean none at all
it's uh so this is what the Chinese have
decided they want their youth to see
could you could that not be an argument
that in China talking about the CCP in
any way that's not positive would be
difficult to do no matter how you put
your finger on the balance of the
of the platform they have a broader
structure that stops people from doing
that 100 and some people would argue
they shouldn't be our role model but
even if you take even if you take the
societal issues and the complicated
conversation around censorship and media
because whenever you hear hear the words
ban and media in the same sentence you
should understandably have a gag reflex
because I think one of the keys to a
productive Democratic Society is that
pretty much anyone can say pretty much
anything about pretty much anyone else I
do think that's super important
but
take that push that aside should Chinese
sectors and companies have unfettered
access to our markets when we have
absolutely none to theirs
yeah Twitter Google meta what's our
access over there zero
we have limited access we have just
enough access initially and they create
body language and a head fake that they
might let us be in there just long
enough so they can steal the
intellectual property they then prop up
a local entrepreneur fund that local
entrepreneur and their attitude is we
can steal the Google algorithm or create
something a reasonable facsimile and
there's probably a two or three hundred
billion dollar company
uh search engine that can just feed off
the domestic Market what do you know
it's Baidu why on Earth are we going to
go the Western Way
and go would do what Italy or South
Korea does and let our newspapers go out
of business and let all of the
shareholder value transfer to California
I mean you got to admire them from a
Chinese standpoint it's really really
meanwhile the limiting the amount of
time that their children can play video
games one hour between 8 and 9 pm Friday
Saturday Sunday per week that's it the
only way that you can play games is
through a streaming service the
streaming service just to just flick the
switch it's just not on you can't do it
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]